Game of Thrones Season seven episode 2
let's begin we start with a storm on
Dragonstone which is significant to
Daenerys because she was born during a
storm on Dragonstone after a father King
Aerys was a thrown by Robert sure no
brother Viserys fled Dragonstone and
went east
now some 16 years later she returns to
reclaim her throne
Dany questions beerus and point out that
he served both King Aerys and King
Robert and he plotted against both of
them Varys also backed Viserys until he
turned out to be useless and under
orders from Robert Varys once sent an
assassin to kill Danny though he also
warned Jorah so that he could protect
her point is Varys betrayed all of these
people so how can Daenerys trust him
Varys says he grew up as an orphan and a
slave and he'll support whoever protects
the people so long as Danny is a good
ruler he'll be loyal because he serves
the realm when he says this in the books
it's probably a lie Varys has complex
motivations relating to Illyrio and
family go watch this video but in the
show this seems to be the simple truth
Varys really just believes that Daenerys
could be a great ruler but there's still
some tension here because Danny
threatens to burn Varys if he turns on
her which is exactly the sort of thing
that the Mad King did will Dany protect
the people nor will she be more like her
father
Dany then gets a visit from Miller
Sandra like Vera smell was once a slave
and like Varys she served other leaders
before she was with Stannis than with
John melvoin's Danny of the long knife
of the darkness brought by the White
Walkers and she speaks of the prince
that was promised or azor Ahai a hero
prophesied to save the world from this
darkness missandei points out that this
prophecy could refer to a man or a woman
and Mel suggests it might mean both that
Dany and Jon Snow could each have a role
Fire and Ice combined to save the world
from the night there are a lot of
different ideas in the books about how
this might go down according to one
story
the original Ozora high sacrificed his
wife to forge a sword to date the
walkers will John have to kill Danny to
save the world
Tyrion vouchers for John they got along
back in season one so Danny decides to
try to alai with John at Winterfell John
and Sansa and davos took over Denny's
invitation John does like Tyrion and so
does Sansa she was once married to him
remember Devils points out that they
need Danny's dragon fire to kill the
army of the Dead and John learns from
Sam of the dragon glass a dragon star in
which they need to kill the White
Walkers and so John tells the north that
he'll meet the dragon queen a lot of his
Lords don't like the idea
they don't trust Danny they remember how
her father the Mad King killed John's
grandfather and uncle that John says
that they need any support and that he's
the best man to go meet her while he's
gone Sansa will rule the north John
heads down to the Crypt to visit the
tomb of the man who he thinks is his
father Ned Stark Littlefinger slithers
in and does his creepy Peter thing
prodding at Jon's insecurities talking
about how Catelyn never loved him he
mentions cat Ned Tyrion Sansa all people
who Peter has screwed over one way or
another by the time Littlefinger talks
about how much he loves Sansa John has
had enough and chokes Peter against a
wall just like Ned did in season one why
does Peter keep on provoking Starks into
choking him is this like his thing or
what John wants paid not to [ __ ] with
him and storms off leaving us wondering
what's Peters plan here some speculate
that he might try to turn Sansa against
John by revealing the truth of John's
parentage that he's not the son of Ned
Stark but is actually the son of Lyanna
stark and rhaegar targaryen should a
Targaryen bastard be allowed to rule the
north there's no evidence that Peter
knows about this though so he might need
a different strategy for Sansa this will
be her first big political test she's
never ruled a kingdom before will she
rise to the challenge will be swayed by
a little finger
other capitals Searcy meets with some
lords and speaks some classic political
spin to make her look like a good leader
and Daenerys look like the enemy she
says Danny brings foreign on solid
soldiers and rapists Dothraki bad
hombres who will burn and pillage
Westeros which may well be true we've
seen Dothraki at war before and it's not
pretty
so she reminds the Lords that Dany is
the mad Kings daughter and that she
killed and tortured people in Mereen
which again is true just like a modern
politician so she uses fear to win a
subject support but the most important
Lord here is randyll Tarly father of Sam
and dick on Randall is a powerful
military leader in the reach he's sworn
to a Lana Tyrell who supports Daenerys
but Jamie suggests that if Randall helps
sir--they instead they'll give Randall
the rule of the reach and this has some
basis in the books the Tyrells were
originally stewards and the only reason
they now rule the reach is because they
just sort of happened to be in the right
place right time to hand Highgarden to
Aegon the conquerer the other houses of
the reach always thought that was kind
of [ __ ] and there are hints that
some hope to overthrow the Tyrells so it
does make sense that Randall might
change sides for Cersei that as Randall
points out so she faces the same problem
that the rage face with Aegon centuries
ago how do you beat three giant
fire-breathing dragons Coburn says he
has a solution they go to the basement
where the old tug Aryan dragon skulls
are kept including the skull of valerian
a famous massive dragon written by Aegon
during his conquest Carbone unveils a
sort of ballista which punches a hole in
the priceless historical artifact
dragons have been killed by this kind of
weapon in Thrones before so it
essentially poses a danger to Danny's
dragons also it is kind of funny seeing
Cersei with a big crossbow since her son
Joffrey also liked those kinds of
weapons
this week on embarrassing bodies arch
mr. Ebers tells Jorah Mormont that he's
going to die the greyscale infection has
spread too far and he'll soon lose his
mind and become a stone man to join the
others in Valyria unless he chooses
instead to commit suicide
wants to save Jorah and points out that
Shireen Baratheon was cured of greyscale
but II bro says that only children can
survive it like that
some fans theorize that since
dragonglass is mentioned as a cure for
greyscale in this book last episode and
Shireen lived on Dragonstone which is
built on a mountain of dragonglass
maybe somehow that's what saved Shireen
like in South Park when Magic Johnson
survives aids by sleeping on cash one
way or another
Sam is determined to help Jorah partly
because he's the son of Jeor Mormont who
was Lord Commander to Sam in the Nights
Watch so that night Sam sneaks a jurors
chamber to heal him it's crazy how in
book one Sam was so nervous and shy and
afraid that he could barely even look at
a dead man now he's secretly performing
forbidden experimental surgery on a
highly contagious greyscale patient Sam
so much braver now so he starts the
procedure on Jorah using some kind of
paste which might be made of dragonglass
as suggested in this book we don't know
the details we only know the process is
painful and so dangerous that it's
forbidden in the books a character
called Victarion has his injured arm
treated in a mysterious process that
gives him a magic super-powered smoking
burnt firearm and some readers hope this
might happen to Jorah though it's not
looking super likely here we'll just
have to wait and see for the results of
this treatment but another cool thing in
Old Town is that Ebro is writing a
history book and sam suggests it should
have a poetic title some fans speculate
that sam is the author of A Song of Ice
and Fire
the Game of Thrones books like maybe the
series will end with him putting down
his pen like Frodo in Lord of the Rings
that's assuming though that Sam will
even survive this story at Dragonstone
Dany plants or invasion of Westeros she
could just fly into King's Landing with
her dragons first Cersei and take the
throne so that would be a bit too easy
wouldn't it tyrion says attacking the
capital would cost too many lives so
instead they'll put the city under siege
with forces from dawn and the reach
while grey worm and the unsullied
take Casterly Rock it's questionable
whether this plan makes any sense
because you probably could take King's
Landing without much loss of life if you
just flew to the Red Keep and didn't
start any fires while besieging the city
will starve people and hurt the common
folk which is exactly what Tyrion hopes
to avoid the geography is also weird
because Danny must have passed on on a
way up to Dragonstone now she's sending
a fleet back down to dawn then north
again to pick up soldiers geography has
kind of gone out the window since the
show passed the books but they're just
trying to keep things dramatic it would
be boring if Danny just won this war
instantly you've got to show her
fighting and give her a chance to lose
there's also drama amongst Danny's war
council because ilaria killed Tyrians
niece Marcela and also though Tyrion
doesn't know it al enna helped frame
Tyrion for Joffrey's murder maybe
that'll come up later there's also an
intimate scene with green worm and
Masson die which some people felt was
pointless but there is some meaning here
grey worm and Miss and I were both
slaves
their bodies were property tools for
violence and obedience but here they
defy their former masters by instead
using their bodies for love
which is kind of beautiful we see aya
bump into hot pie who was a companion
for a while until he came to this in
while everyone else has been hour
fighting and dying hot pie has been
baking and surviving he asks aya what
happened to her and she doesn't answer
how could she since they last met aya
rode with the Hound murdered some people
joined a death cult murdered more people
went blind got stabbed lost a friend
slayed some phrase and met Ed Sheeran
how could she begin to explain all of
this trauma all of the things that she's
done as well as providing pie hot pie
gives is some information he mentions
that everyone knows that so she blew up
the scepter King's Landing so it's kind
of hard to see how people are so cool
with her after she killed all of these
people hope I also says that the Starks
have retaken Winterfell and that jon is
king so I decide not to kill Cersei but
instead to reunite with her family that
human connection is more important to
her and killing aya was especially close
to Jon growing up and they miss each
other a lot throughout the series there
have been hints in the books they'd
reunite but it might not happen this
time because just as I is head
the Winterfell John's leaving for
Dragonstone but as I arrives north she
has a different reunion with a direwolf
Nymeria I an Iberia were close in season
one but they had to split up after
Nymeria saved ire from Joffrey in the
books iya stays magically connected -
Nymeria over distance having wolf dreams
where she controls NIMS body in her
sleep
Nymeria grows into a monstrous she-wolf
leading a great pack of man-eating
wolves across the Riverlands series
author George Martin has hinted that the
pack might be part of the story later on
in the show though this scene has the
tone of a farewell I asked him to come
without a Winterfell but she doesn't and
ayah says that's not you this refers to
a bit in season one when Ned tells aya
about the life she should live as a lady
in a castle wearing a pretty dress and I
a response that that's not me I is
fierce and independent she won't live
the domestic life and now Nymeria is the
same she's a wild wolf strong and free
and she won't go home to be a pet again
now Mira's experiences have changed her
just like Aya's experiences have changed
her and maybe like 9 the area aya will
struggle to come home to reconnect to
the people she had known in Danny's
fleet the sand snakes argue like a bunch
of psychopaths over who gets to kill the
Lannisters and a mountain
the snakes want revenge for their father
Oberyn and for their and Elia were both
killed by the mountain under Lannister
orders meanwhile ilaria hits on Yara
making feel uncomfortable when suddenly
Uncle Euron pays a visit his Ironborn
are in their element here attacking at
sea by night and Euron himself goes into
beast mode fighting for Rochas lee we've
never seen Euron fight in the books he
tends to use words and magic to harm
people show Euron seems a bit like his
brother Victarion the guy with the
smoking arm who is known to be handy
with an axe
so yeah you Ron wins this battle and
kills ybarra and Nymeria a bar is
impaled on our own spear and Nymeria
hanged from our own whip which
symbolically is pretty appropriate the
fountain aches caused
their own downfall their obsession with
killing to avenge their family led them
to kill their own family a borrower
kills cousin Christine
ilaria kills Duran and now a Barra annum
a dead two consumed in their quest for
vengeance but the great trauma of this
battle is with the Greyjoy family Euron
captures his knee Sierra and taunts
Theon to come save her Yara has risked
her life to save Theon before shouldn't
they on do the same the Theon of season
1 might have done the heroic thing like
when he saved bran in season 1 but the
Theon of season 1 is dead after the
trauma he suffered around his hands
Theon's changed into someone too afraid
to save his sister and so Theon flees
leaving Yara behind urine for his part
seems to feed off this pain he loves
psychologically tormenting people in the
books he sexually abuses two of his
brothers and murders 3 he tortures
dismembers and brutalized as many he
gets a girl pregnant only to rip out her
tongue and chained her to his ship as
part of a blood magic sacrifice to make
himself into some kind of dark God book
Euron is capital a evil and we're
starting to see hints of this in the
show so things are kicking up a notch
loose plot threads like the sand snakes
and Varys is uncertain boil tea of
getting quickly cut to make way for the
central conflicts I is identity so sees
power Theon's pain Danny's conquest and
the Song of Ice and Fire
fighting white walkers for the dawn
thanks for watching
a lot of the ideas in this video come
from the Song of Ice and Fire fan
community so go check out the subreddit
and Westeros dog thanks to the
translators for translating captions and
thanks to the patrons for making this
possible including Miriam ever Daniel
Burkhart Zach Gordon Clayton and sting
of Z's or Nathan Gaza and Geena penny
Cheers
you